- It's crazy.
Once again, if I
was to write this,
let's say 10 years ago,
as a political thriller,
it would go in the
science fiction
or the dystopian thriller
aisle at the bookstore.
No one would have believed it
if I had written the
exact same things
that are going on in
this country today,
and internationally,
and put that into a novel,
it would've been unbelievable.
The reviews on Amazon would say,
"Ah, can't believe any of this.
"This would never happen,"
that sort of thing, one star,
but lo and behold,
look what's going on.
(authoritative music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is a Navy SEAL sniper,
and number-one "New York
Times" bestselling author
and now author of the
brand-new book "In the Blood,"
Jack Carr.
Finally, welcome to
"The Rubin Report."
- Oh, thank you so
much for having me on.
Great to see you.
- I have wanted to have
you on for quite some time.
First off, I gotta
say, I had to say,
number-one "New York
Times" bestselling author,
even though the "New York Times"
left me off their bestseller
list just weeks ago,
but you got the number-one spot.
It's still credit to you,
so it sort of stabbed
me a little bit.
I'm kinda in the
blood right now,
but you deserve the credit,
and I went ahead
and did it anyway.
- Well, I sincerely
appreciate that,
and as we know, it's hard.
The number one and number two,
maybe number-three
slots on that list,
it's hard for them to ignore,
but they have some
flexibility down there
with those other ones as an
editorial, I think it was found,
I don't know, 30,
40, 50 years ago,
whenever that was
brought up to the courts,
so they have a little
flexibility there,
but that's why the goal
has to always be number one
so they can't ignore you.
- Exactly. Exactly.
Well, you did get number
one. It says it right here.
I just said to you,
before we started,
the cover of this
book is just awesome.
The colors, it
just freaking hits.
You got a couple
of them behind you
so first off, I just
gotta start with,
I mean, your whole
operation there.
I'm feeling very
stuffy right now.
You are obviously,
you are in your
bunker somewhere safe.
What's going on over there?
- This is true.
Undisclosed location,
but I like to be surrounded by
things that mean a lot to me,
the crossed Winkler tomahawks
that are used in the book
and that Amazon actually
allowed us to use in the series
and feature prominently
with Chris Pratt
that's coming out this summer,
but probably like this one.
This is Hemingway's
typewriter right here,
- Wow.
- and he wrote
You wrote "A Moveable
Feast" on this.
It went up for auction,
which a bunch of other
Hemingway stuff in January,
early February of 2020,
so right before the
COVID panic really hit,
and a fan got it for me, and
didn't wanna be recognized,
but knew I had this,
just a fan of Hemingway
and thought that
I would enjoy this
and that I would appreciate it,
and so they sent it to me
with all the documentation
and the whole thing,
and yeah, it's crazy, so
that inspires me as I write.
- Man, you've done
something right in life
when someone you don't know
buys you Ernest
Hemingway's typewriter.
- It's crazy.
Crazy.
- Pretty solid.
Pretty solid, so for my
audience that does not know you
or only knows about
you from your writing,
et cetera, et cetera,
gimme a little bit
of the history,
the Navy SEAL, all that stuff
'cause you you have pretty
extraordinary history yourself.
- Well, I appreciate that,
and yeah, I feel very fortunate
in that I always knew
I wanted to serve my country
in uniform, very early age.
My grandfather served
in World War II
and didn't make it home.
He was killed in the
Pacific in May of 1945,
but I grew up with the maps
that they used to give
aviators back then,
which were silk so
that if they got wet,
you could still use them,
and they didn't
disintegrate like paper,
pictures of him and his
squadron, his medals, his wings.
He was a Marine aviator,
so I was just drawn to the
military from a very early age,
and then, at the ripe
old age of seven,
I found out about SEALs,
and my mom was a librarian,
so went down to the local
library to do some research,
and there wasn't very
much written about SEALs
or special operations back then.
There were a few
articles here and there,
couple chapters
in a book or two,
but my takeaway that,
"Hey, these guys
"are some of the most elite
special operators in the world,
"and the training is
some of the toughest
"ever devised by a
modern military,"
so whether that was true or not,
seven-year-old Jack was all in,
and the recruiter had to
do nothing, essentially.
I made their job very easy,
so I kept my eyes on that
for, really, my entire life,
but I also started
reading the books
that my parents were reading
in about fifth grade,
so that's when Tom Clancy's
"Hunt for Red
October" comes out,
and I'm reading David
Morrell and Nelson DeMille
and A.J. Quinnell and J.C.
Pollock and Marc Olden
and all these guys
whose protagonists,
whose main characters had
backgrounds in Vietnam,
either as like Marine
snipers back then,
or it was Navy SEALs
or Army Special Forces
or CIA paramilitary.
That was the typical background
of your '80s action hero
in the thriller genre,
and then on screen as well,
so it was so magical for
me to read these books
and those guys were
really my professors
in the art of storytelling,
although I didn't look at
it like that at the time.
I was just a fan,
and I knew that after
my time in the military,
I would write books like this,
the books that I was
enjoying as a kid growing up,
so I never stopped that reading,
never stopped that
studying of warfare,
whether the terrorism
insurgencies,
counterinsurgencies,
special operations,
that was all just a
part of my upbringing,
and it was part
of the foundation
that allowed me to be
the operator that I was,
the leader that I was
in the SEAL teams,
and then, all of that comes
together as I'm getting out
to write these thrillers,
so I did 20 years
in the SEAL team,
started out enlisted,
was a sniper,
then became an officer, finished
up as a troop commander,
and interestingly enough,
that's where the reader
meets my protagonist
in my first novel.
He's a troop commander
on his way out,
and then disaster and
conspiracy strikes,
and off we go to the races.
- Crazy how those
things connect, huh?
- It is, and it
wasn't the intent.
I thought there were gonna be
two separate chapters in life,
but when I sat down to
write that first one,
it became readily apparent
that it was gonna be more
than just the technical details
of a sniper weapon system
or something like that.
It was really the
emotions and the feelings
behind certain events
that I was involved in
that I could bring to a
completely fictional narrative,
so if my main
character, James Reece,
is getting ambushed
in Los Angeles,
I can go back and
remember what it was like
to be ambushed in Baghdad in
2006 at the height of the war,
and I can take those
feelings and emotions
and apply them to this
completely fictional narrative,
which is why I think it stood
out to Simon & Schuster,
who sees thousands
of books like these
cross their desks every year.
- Yeah, gimme the
best and worst moment
of being a SEAL.
I suspect I can guess the
worst, but maybe the best,
- Yeah, the worst, obviously,
is when your friend
doesn't make it home,
and you go to those funerals,
and you pound your
trident into the coffin,
and you see that
widow or the kids,
and so that's obviously
the worst part of it,
but the best part of it,
gosh, I never really thought
of the best part of it,
but I think it's the
entire experience
in that you have a purpose.
You have a mission.
Your passion is being
the best operator
that you can possibly be.
You owe that to the guys
to your right and left,
to their families, to the team,
to the country as a whole,
to that entire mission,
so I think it's that.
I guess it would be
the having that purpose
that is so clearly defined,
and when you're down range
being solely focused
on that task at hand
and not having to worry
about anything else,
not worrying about the
leaky faucet or the gutters
or the baby that's
crying or whatever it is,
you were solely focused
on that task at hand,
building patterns of life
on your targeted individuals
and then going out
and grabbing them in
the middle of the night
to bring them back,
ask them a couple questions,
and then go take out the
rest of that network,
so having that purpose
that is so clear, I think,
is probably one
of the best parts.
- So one of the things
that I'm always amazed by
is that those of you guys that
have been in the military,
been SEALs, been in the
Navy, whatever it is,
or people that have been
in the CIA, the FBI.
Just a couple weeks ago,
I had Bryan Dean
Wright on the show.
I don't know if who he is,
but he's a former CIA guy.
People that get out
and then do things
that are ancillarily
related to this,
whether it's talking on
YouTube for a living,
whether it's writing books
that are either fiction or
nonfiction, everything else,
how do you blend?
You know some stuff
that they probably don't
want you to talk about.
There's a way
that you have to fictionize
some of these things.
You don't wanna get in trouble.
You don't wanna become a
character in one of your books.
How do you take
all of those things
and make it honest and sensible
and also not so you're gonna
get yourself killed, literally.
- (chuckles) Right, so
a lot of people think,
on the outside looking in,
that Navy SEALs know all
sorts of secret stuff,
and maybe there's a couple
things here and there,
but really, what we're doing is
what every major city SWAT
team is gonna do tonight.
They're gonna go
serve a warrant.
They're gonna go do
either a no-knock or a
knock warrant somewhere.
They're gonna bust in, and
they're gonna grab a fugitive,
so we're doing that same thing
except ours happen to
be in Baghdad or Kabul
or somewhere
somewhere like that,
and we have a few more
maybe assets at our disposal
to build these targets,
build these target packages
and then go prosecute
these targets,
but there's not much
secret about it.
I mean, you're just,
you're going up
and kicking a door in
the middle of the night
and grabbing somebody outta
their bed, essentially,
but I still wanted to make sure
that I was complying
with all the everything
that I had signed
in the military,
and I didn't wanna
give anything away,
and I was still closely related,
closely connected to my military
time for that first novel,
so I submitted it to the...
I got some lawyers,
and they said, "Yeah, we
recommend you submit this,"
so I did,
and they took out, I
think, like nine sentences,
so not much.
It was pretty good,
and they got back
to me with, 45 days.
They advertise 30,
and what you sign says they
will get back to you in 30.
They got back to me in 45.
I thought that was pretty
good for the government,
so I did that for the
second one as well.
That one, one month went by,
then two, then three,
then four, then seven,
and we had to push
the publication date,
and they got back,
and they took out 54
sentences, passages, words,
so at this point,
I can afford a little bit,
afford some more attorney fees,
so we go, and we appeal,
and we tie each and every
one of those redactions
to a publicly available
government document,
so not to someone else's
book or to Wikipedia,
but something anyone in
the world can download
from our very own government.
They let me win on 37,
so now you can go
to the paperback,
and you can look in there,
and you compare it
to the hardcover,
and you can see what they
were concerned about,
but that I won on appeal.
One of those things,
I made up a completely
fictitious CIA black
site in Morocco.
They took out Morocco.
They took out
Moorish architecture.
They took out the
Atlas Mountains.
They took out everything
that could pinpoint where it,
what country this,
and I had no, in my
military experience,
no touchpoints with Moroccan
intelligence services
or military, anything like that.
I just made it up, but
by doing that appeal,
what are they telling us?
Well, now they're telling us
that there's probably
a CIA black site-
(Dave laughing drowns out Jack)
so if they'd done nothing,
it would've been more
beneficial to them
than had they gone
through this process,
so I did that for the
first three novels.
The third one, when we appealed,
they got back and said,
"Hey, we're not gonna
let you appeal,"
and I took that as,
"Quit bothering us, kid,
"with this fiction."
(Dave laughs)
- We're not gonna
let you appeal.
That's probably the
best thing you can hear
from the government
in your shoes.
- Yeah, I'll take it.
I'll take it, so
the next one was
I went deep down the rabbit
hole, in my fourth one,
into bioweapons and
bioweapons research,
and so I'm glad I
didn't submit that one.
It was all, once again,
I had no touchpoints with
bioweapons in the military,
but I went deep down
the rabbit hole,
and then, on this one,
on "In the Blood,"
deep down the rabbit hole
on quantum computing,
artificial intelligence
and mass data surveillance
and data storage
of U.S. citizens,
and that was more terrifying
than the bioweapons research
that I did on the
previous novel.
- That sorta tells you
everything you need
to know about that,
so you're making the movie,
and as you mentioned,
Chris Pratt is gonna
be in the movie,
and Chris Pratt, who's
an awesome actor,
and what I think is so
interesting about him is
the guy has managed
to stay in Hollywood
despite his politics
being outside of the
norm of Hollywood.
How involved were
you in the casting
and just the creation
of the movie?
Because, obviously,
you writing a book,
doing it in your little
operation over there,
or I don't know how,
I can't say little,
but your very cool operation
over there is very different
than when you hand your
baby over to Hollywood,
and Hollywood may
not be so in line
with perhaps some of
the things in the book,
perhaps the type of people
that you want involved,
et cetera, et cetera.
- Exactly, I didn't know
what to expect going in,
just like I didn't
know what to expect
from Simon & Schuster going in.
I thought they might
wanna change everything
and give me some,
at least maybe hint that
maybe I shouldn't be...
Do you really have
to put this in there
about the Second Amendment?
Or does your character really
have to think this way?
They have never even hinted
at me changing anything.
I've had complete creative
control, which is amazing,
but when you option something,
especially when it's
before your first novel
even hits shelves,
you're not really negotiating
from a position of strength,
and so they have all the rights,
can do whatever they want,
and so when you're
in that position,
there's a lot of trust involved,
and I was so lucky
that I had Chris Pratt,
Antoine Fuqua as the director,
an incredible show runner,
and the three of us just got
together in the beginning,
and what was
important to all of us
was keeping that
dark, gritty, violent,
primal nature of the book
'cause that's really what
resonated with people
and broke it out from
maybe others in the genre,
but the way that Chris Pratt
even found out about it
before it hit shelves
is interesting
in that I got a call from a
SEAL buddy in November of 2017,
so a few months before
the book's gonna come out,
and first he asked if I
remembered him, which I did,
and then he asked
if I remembered what I did
for him in the SEAL teams,
which I did not,
and he said, "You're
the only person
"that sat me down
in your office,
"helped me through
the transitioning
out of the military,
"introduced me to people
in the private sector.
"Nobody else did that.
"Always wanted to
say thank you,"
and I said, "How's it going?"
And he said, "Well,
it's going great,
"but I heard you wrote a book,
and I said, "Yeah, it's
coming out in a few months.
"I can send you a galley copy.
"It's like a rough draft thing,"
and he said, "Yeah,
I'd like that,
"but I'd like to give
it to a friend of mine,"
and I said, "Who's that?"
And he said, "Chris Pratt,"
and what was even more
interesting about that
is that as I was writing,
I thought of Chris Pratt
playing the main character,
and I thought of
Antoine Fuqua directing,
and another SEAL buddy
got it to Antoine Fuqua,
who wanted it,
and Chris and Antoine
wanted it at the same time,
so finally, Antoine called Chris
and said, "Let's
do this together,"
and now we're all executive
producers on this thing,
but it's a credit to Amazon
for the things that they could,
well, they were concerned about
a few things from the book,
but really, all that ended
up being was concern,
and once we talked
about different scenes
that we needed in there and
wanted to have in there,
that the fans would
want in there,
they came down on the right
side of it each and every time,
as uncomfortable as it
may have been for them,
they sided with us,
and it's all in there,
so couldn't be happier
with how that worked out.
- What do you make of the
state of sort of the...
Well, what do you call
the genre, actually?
Like, military
thriller, or what are-
- Thriller, if you have
to put it in something.
It's a political thriller,
for the most part,
but there's all sorts
of thrillers out there.
There's legal thrillers
and medical thrillers
and dystopian thrillers
and all that stuff,
but yeah, it's a
political thriller.
- So political thrillers,
and I think of the
more in certain,
like there's certain
political ones
that are very much
in the politics part
and then ones that are a little
more in the military part.
I can think of so many.
You mentioned Tom Clancy.
I mean, I can think of
so many incredible movies
from the '80s or
really sorta early '90s
that were just like,
there were just,
every other week there was
just another awesome movie.
You mentioned "Hunt
for Red October."
What do you make of the
state of the genre right now?
Because everything is so
politicized these days.
I find, when I open up
Netflix or Hulu or Amazon,
for me, personally,
as a politics guy,
I'm often trying to avoid
politics a little bit.
That's just me,
but what do you make of the
general state of things?
And I'm a guy that
I love explosions.
I love thrillers. I love
all of these movies.
I'm just curious what
your take on that is.
- Yeah, it was something that
I was concerned about going in
that other people that were
involved in the project
were concerned about as well
because, as we all know,
if you've scrolled through
any of the streaming platforms
or gone to a movie recently,
it seems like a
lot of the movies
are made for people
in L.A. or New York,
and forget about
everyone in between,
so we really wanted to make sure
we didn't forget about
everybody in between,
and it was interesting
in that a lot of people's
view of Hollywood
comes from seeing maybe a
clip of the Academy Awards
or a Golden Globes
and (indistinct)
an actor, a director,
or a producer on stage
saying something kinda crazy,
and you're kinda like,
"Oh, Hollywood people
are all totally weird,"
and, "Oh, my goodness, I can
see where this is going,"
but on set,
I had 350 people on
set making this series.
It's an eight-part
series for Amazon,
and (indistinct) this
thing called video village,
so the executive producers,
and we have our screens, and
we have our headphones on,
and we can watch what's going on
and make notes and
all the rest of it,
and the other executive
producers told me
they hadn't seen this before,
but so many people on
that set would come up,
track me down there,
and like the hair and makeup
person would come in and say,
"Hey, my son is going
to boot camp tomorrow.
"He's a huge fan. He
follows you on Instagram.
"Would you sign a book?"
And I always had a
big box of books there
and would sign away,
or someone would
come up and say,
"Hey, my son's going on
his first deployment.
"Can you sign this for him?"
And absolutely, and so
we'd talk about guns.
We'd talk about Land Cruisers.
We'd talk about knives.
We'd talk about hunting and
just normal people talk,
and what was so extraordinary
is that they're so
good at their job,
but also, they just wanna put
food on their family's table,
and these are just normal
Americans that are working hard,
and we had American flags up,
all the Teamsters truck had
their American flags flying,
and it was a special set,
and people made a
point to tell me
that they've been
on hundreds of sets,
and they've never felt one
that was as open and welcoming
and encouraging and positive
and just a cool and
American as this one,
and I thought that was, that
made me feel good anyway.
- I can tell you, as somebody
that just fled Los Angeles
after eight years there,
there were awful lot
of people that I knew
that were in the biz
that were waking up,
that were sort of
lefties their whole life
or were into a lot
of the craziness,
and suddenly they were
going, "Wait a minute.
"I can't get a job
"'cause I'm a
60-something-year-old
white guy,"
or, "I don't fit this diversity
thing," or something else,
or the street that they
live on was burning down,
and they suddenly got guns.
I was one of those
people in L.A.
that didn't have guns
before all this craziness,
and then, suddenly, reality
hits you in the face,
and you kinda change
your view on things.
- Yeah, I got so many texts,
first, when COVID hit,
and people were a
little worried about,
"Hey, is there gonna
be food on the shelf,"
or, "Is somebody gonna be there
"at the other end
of when I call 911?"
Then, of course,
when the summer of civil unrest
hit us a few months later,
the same thing: I was
getting texts and phone calls
and e-mails from people in
California, in particular,
asking about what
gun should I get?
And then them being surprised
that they just can't run
down and just get one,
just pay in cash and walk
out with one the same day,
or why they couldn't
get ammunition
sent to their house
in Los Angeles.
These things were a
shock to a lot of people
who just from what you
think in the news is that,
"Oh yeah, anybody
can just walk in.
"You walk out with some
fully automatic, boom-boom,
"and stacks of ammo
and all that stuff,"
yet they've been voting people
into office there for so long
that they don't have
those rights anymore.
They've outsourced those
to a government that is,
whose leaders are surrounded
by taxpayer-funded security
when they're trying to
take your rights away,
and we see that, of course,
all across the country now,
but California,
Chicago, of course,
a couple other, New
York stands out,
stand out from the
crowd in that regard,
so I did get a lot of
phone calls like that,
and there were a lot
of shocked people
that they couldn't just go in
and get any firearm
that they wanted.
- You are preaching
my language, brother.
Actually, I can't say
who it is out loud,
but when all hell was
breaking loose in L.A.,
I happened to say
on the show one day,
"I'm thinking about getting
guns for the first time,"
and I got a call from a
major Hollywood sitcom star,
a woman who would never want
me to say her name on air,
and she said, "Hey, if you
need guns, let me know,"
and she ended up
connecting me with people,
and that's how I
was able to get guns
'cause yeah, you're right:
you couldn't get
ammo either in L.A.
because it was,
because so many people were
flipping on all of this stuff.
Do you-
- Yeah-
- Do you feel a certain...
Oh, sorry. Go ahead.
- No, I said you
couldn't even order it.
You can't even order it and get
it delivered in Los Angeles.
I think that's just
a county thing,
but anyway, yeah, they make
it extremely difficult.
In the military it would be
like motorcycles on base,
so they didn't want you to
ride a motorcycle on base,
so first, they did, "Okay,
you have to take this course."
Okay, so you have to
take like three days
to take this course,
so okay, you gotta
take this course.
You have to do like an up.
You do it every year, and
then you have to have gloves.
You have to have shoes
that cover your ankle.
You have to have long sleeves,
helmet, reflector vest.
They started adding all these
administrative requirements,
and finally, it's
like, "Okay, you win.
"I'm exhausted.
"This whole year is gonna
be trying to figure out
"how to ride my
motorcycle onto base here.
"Fine, you've got it,"
so that's kind of
what governments do
to try to make it if they,
"Oh, we're not
making guns illegal."
Well, you're making
them administratively
impossible to get,
like you've done with
concealed carry permits
in a lot of states.
- That's actually
a perfect segue
to what I wanted to get to
next relative to just generally
what's going on
with the military.
What do you make of the state
of the military at the moment
and the state of the
way that it seems
politics has really
infected the military,
at least in the last,
say, 5, 10 years,
that it didn't
seem it did before,
or maybe we didn't
know about it before?
- Yep, so obviously,
politics has been creeping
into all aspects of our
culture for a long time.
People like to
point to Hollywood,
but hey, look at
there's Wall Street,
more and more into sports.
I mean, almost every,
education, of course,
but really, every
aspect of society.
We thought the military
was immune from that,
and we found out, over
the last couple years,
that it is most certainly not,
and really, not even
talking about that,
the wokeness in the military
or anything like that.
We can just go and look at
20 years of our experience
in Iraq and Afghanistan
and how none of our
senior military leaders
have been held accountable for
the decisions that they made,
and we can go back
and look at each and
every one of these guys
with stars on their shoulders
sitting in front of Congress
saying the exact same
things year after year.
You can take the year off there,
and it's a different person,
but the audio will
be exactly the same:
"(indistinct) meeting
our milestones."
"The Afghan National Army
"is getting closer to being
able to stand up on their own.
"We just need more
resources, more people,
"more funding, more
equipment," whatever it is,
and then "The Afghanistan
Papers" was published,
and I hope more people read
"The Afghanistan Papers"
by Craig Whitlock
because what he does is
takes these interviews
that these senior-level leaders
thought were gonna
remain classified,
juxtaposes it with
what they were saying
in front of Congress, so
to the American people,
to Congress, to their troops,
and essentially, you
have two separate stories
180 out from one another,
and so they're essentially
lying to their troops,
lying to Congress, lying
to the American people,
and these senior-level
leaders continue to fail up,
and we see what happens
when we continue to do
that year after year
and hold no senior-level
leaders accountable.
We have a withdrawal
from Afghanistan
that looks like what
we saw last August,
which the media, of course,
doesn't even talk about anymore,
but we all got to watch
with our own eyes,
and it's also why
everyone in this country
with a little bit
of common sense
could comment on it
because you didn't need to have
a touchpoint with the military
or study strategy or tactics
or military history at all.
You could just look at that
and apply some common sense,
which is something that
Carl von Clausewitz said
was most important aspect
of any military leader,
any combat leader is
having common sense,
and so anyone could look at that
and say, "Why are we giving up
"this tactically advantageous
position at Bagram
"and putting America's
sons and daughters
"into tactically
disadvantageous position
"when we've had 20 years to
prepare for this eventuality?"
And this is the best the
United States military can do?
This is the best that we have.
This is what are giving
our sons and daughters
as we're putting them
in this position.
Now, if you'd done that
at the tactical level,
as an O-3, so as a
captain in the Army
or a lieutenant in the
Navy or something like that
or as a chief in the Navy
or something, a sergeant,
you'd be court-martialed,
sent home if you just...
And our senior-level
leaders, what do they do?
All those people are
still in those positions.
If they've retired,
they're on the board at
Raytheon or General Dynamics
or something like that,
so when we look at
lobbyists and politicians
and think tanks and that
military-industrial complex,
that's a real thing.
That's an animal,
and when it's not held to check
and no one's held accountable,
you get things
like the disastrous
withdrawal from Afghanistan,
essentially rushing to our death
after 20 years of
being able to prepare
and plan for that eventuality.
It's inexcusable.
- So I don't know
if this about me,
but every August, I go
off the grid for a month:
no phone, no news,
no communication with
the outside world.
I literally disappear
for a month,
so the August, this
past August, obviously,
was the Afghanistan withdrawal,
so I did not know that
until September 1st.
I come back and I
have a guest host.
It was Adam Carolla
this past year
who kinda caught me up
to speed on everything,
so I was seeing all those
videos two weeks later
all in real time for the first
time in front of my audience,
and what I said to Adam
watching them in real time was
from what I could tell,
just seeing it all
right in front of me,
right at that
moment, all at once,
that this could not
have been worse,
that if you had intentionally
tried to bungle something
at the highest level,
that that's pretty much what
it would've looked like.
Do you think that's
a fair estimation?
I mean, 20 years from now, when
we look back on this thing,
what do you think the
postmortem is gonna look like?
- Well, if it's
honest, it's gonna be
exactly what you what you
just said right there.
You could not have
bungled this worse
had you actually been trying,
and once again, it's that
accountability piece,
but what we had,
we had 20 years of our own
experience to look back on,
to take lessons from, to
apply going forward as wisdom.
We didn't even have to
go back to the Soviets.
I mean, we should have earlier
on gone back to '79 to '89,
the Soviet experience
in Afghanistan.
We didn't have to go back to
the three British incursions
in the 1800s, early 1900s.
Certainly didn't have to go back
to Alexander the
Great, Genghis Khan,
although we could have,
and we could have taken lessons
from all of those things
and applied them to our
present situation as wisdom,
yet we did not.
We think of things in terms
of four-year election cycles,
eight-year election cycles
for the real deep
thinkers among us,
but what we neglect to do is
go back in the pages of
history, take those lessons,
and apply them going forward,
and that's obviously
to the detriment
of our sons and daughters
who are out there
on the front line,
and we saw in Afghanistan,
13 lost their lives,
to say nothing of those
who lost arms and legs
and can't walk anymore
and are dealing with the
post-traumatic stress
or traumatic brain injury
from a position that
they were put in
by our senior-level leaders.
- Is it crazy to you
how quickly we just move
off things like that?
I mean, as you said,
it was the longest war
in American history.
We were there for 20 years.
It was very unclear
to a lot of people
sort of why were there and
how it was connected to 9/11
and all of that stuff,
but that basically we
had two or three weeks
of sort of news
cycle and outrage,
and now it's completely
not talked about,
and we've got this situation
in Ukraine right now,
and it's like do
our allies trust us?
Does anyone believe
what we're doing?
Do we have the right
people in charge?
Any of that.
- Yeah, no, those are
valid, valid questions,
and as it pertains
to what's going on
in Afghanistan vis-a-vis,
or in Ukraine vis-a-vis Russia,
once again, we had a lot of data
which to look at and predict
what was gonna happen.
In my second novel,
"True Believer,"
I actually use a false flag
operation that came out in 2019,
but I use a false flag operation
to instigate a Russian
invasion of Ukraine,
and I got that just by studying
the situation at the time,
so I was writing
that in 2016, 2017,
editing it in 2018 so it
could come out in 2019,
but that research should
have shown anybody that,
"Hey, this is
essentially inevitable"
because the Russian population
is in a steep decline
and has been since the
end of the Cold War,
and they are very, a
couple generations away
from there being
no ethnic Russians,
and they're certainly very close
to not being able
to field an army
in the numbers that they have
been able to in the past,
and at the time,
it was about 2022.
There's actually a book called
"The Accidental Superpower"
while Peter Zeihan looks at
geography and demographics
as far as world
history and superpowers
and how that has has played in,
and yeah, 2022 was about the
last year that Russia had
before they would not
be able to field an army
capable of invading Ukraine
because they need
those ethnic Russians,
and Ukraine has the
largest population
of ethnic Russians in the
world outside of Russia,
so these things
were predictable,
and then, of course,
we can go back to World
War I, World War II,
end of the Cold
War, promises made.
We rarely put ourselves
in our enemy's shoes,
and red game things
from that position,
red cell things
but we should do that more often
because we'd make
wiser decisions.
- What do you think
the role of the
American military should
be at this point?
It seems like it really
has sorta changed,
or it seemed like it was
changing, at least, under Trump.
There basically, there
was a lot of peace.
There was a lot of like, "Oh,
if we mess with this guy,
"we don't know what
he's gonna do."
You remember he dropped that
mother of all bombs in Iraq.
Nobody understood
why, and it was like,
"Well, it got pretty
quiet there pretty quick,"
and now we're in this
Ukraine situation.
What do you think
the general role
of America worldwide should be?
- Well, it should be
one of respect and fear
that goes along with that
because that military
is really what,
it's like the Second Amendment
to the First Amendment.
The military, it
backs up everything
that we say and that we do,
so if we have this
strong military
that is more concerned
with other people's borders
rather than our own,
while essentially,
we're seeing an invasion
across our southern
border right now
that's, once again,
not really talked about
in the mainstream press.
It's been going on
for quite some time,
but we have all sorts
of issues like that,
and we have a Department of
Defense after World War II.
It used to be the Department
of War, the War Department.
Then it changed, 1947,
and really, since then,
we haven't done very
well in conflicts,
and that's the exact same time
that accountability shifted,
and by shifted, I
mean that we started
not holding our senior-level
leaders accountable.
When we talk about
George Marshall,
he's most known for the Marshall
Plan after World War II,
but really, what's more
important is what he did
in their lead-up to World War
II and during World War II,
which were fire those
leaders who didn't cut it,
so he put all those
guys in positions
whose names we know today
as leading us through,
that led us through
World War II to victory,
but had he not done that
and just let those people
who were in those places
that weren't cutting it,
I mean, who knows how World
War II would've turned out,
but he fired people that didn't
cut it after World War II,
and we shift over to the
Department of Defense,
things start to
change: Korea, Vietnam,
and obviously,
what we see today,
and we, for whatever
reason, we're hesitant
to hold these senior-level
leaders accountable,
but we can trace
it all the way back
to the end of World
War II and in 1947,
but today, we're in an
interesting position
in that, yes, we
have a technologic,
we have 20 years of experience
and we have this technology
that has just been
racing forward
when it comes to
our weapon systems,
and so we take those
tactical lessons learned,
take these new weapons
and the technology
as far as tracking and targeting
and all the rest of it.
We should have
the most feared
military on the planet,
yet we have a border that's
just porous, essentially,
and we see what we
saw in Afghanistan,
so with all that technology,
all those lessons,
we still get that
outcome in Afghanistan,
so if I'm the enemy,
and I'm looking at that,
that gives me some wiggle room,
and that gives me
some lessons learned
to apply to my
future battle plans
that probably go more than
four to eight years in advance.
I can think decades.
I can think even
centuries if I'm China,
and I can apply these lessons
to those battle plans.
- So it's not that
hopeful, I sense,
is-
- Try to remain hopeful.
Try. Try.
(Dave laughs)
- Well, my audience
knows I always try to,
I try to talk about
the serious stuff,
and then I try to,
there's gotta be something
on the horizon, some hope.
I mean, what are some of
the mechanisms we could do
to fix some of this stuff?
I mean, I don't sense
that this administration
is gonna go in
and fix the things
you're talking about
'cause they seem to be
aiding and abetting it.
You talk about the
southern border.
It's like they're the ones
that are freaking
opening this thing up.
900,000 new people roughly in
the country in the last year,
according to Mayorkas from
Department of Homeland Security,
so what are some of the things
that maybe could be done
to reverse some of
the damage here?
- Yeah, first, it's like
the top three things:
holding senior-level
leaders accountable,
just like you hold
junior-level leaders
or Soldiers, Sailors, Airmen,
and Marines accountable,
so that's one.
That sends a message
'cause when you don't,
what message does that send
to those people who wanna
put a star on their shoulder
or wanna put another
one on their shoulder?
You're sending a message,
regardless of which one of
those things that you do,
so holding those
guys accountable,
one of the top priorities.
Next one, border,
sealing that border.
That has to happen,
and then, third biggest one
is becoming less
reliant on China,
particularly where it comes to
technology side of the house
and pharmaceutical
side of the house,
so things that we're, I
mean, it's just insane
that we are reliant on
essentially our enemy
for things that are paramount
to our national security,
so those three things right
there, and they seem so simple.
Once again, apply common
sense to this problem.
I mean, that's what I
did on the battlefield.
You just look at the
chaos that's going on.
You look for gaps in
the enemy's defenses.
You look to capitalize
on momentum.
You look to adapt
because the enemy's
certainly adapting to you.
That's what I do in
the pages of my novels,
and you can do that same thing
looking strategically
at an issue,
so those three
things, I think, are,
as simple as they sound,
somehow escape the,
I don't know, the thought
process and the strategies
being put forth by our
senior-level elected officials,
not leaders.
I like to make sure that
I differentiate that.
- Indeed, they are elected.
I'll grant them that.
Leaders, I'm not so sure,
at least this current crop.
Are you kind of amazed, though,
at the level of incompetence
or just general ridiculousness?
I mean, during the State
of the Union Address,
Biden's talking about COVID,
and he keeps saying,
"We're gonna get
everybody COVID tests,"
and then he's also saying
that we're gonna be making
things in America again.
He's suddenly repeating
a lot of the Trump stuff,
but when Trump said it, it was
racist; now it's not racist.
Okay, and then the tests
show up at everybody's house,
if you ask for them,
and you're not gonna believe
where they were made:
in China.
- Made in China.
- Can you believe it?
That level of
disconnect between,
I think this is what
you're getting to,
they say one thing, then the
stuff shows up at your door.
Oh, COVID test made in China.
We can't even make
the COVID test here.
This is one of the two big
things you were talking about,
although it was
mostly about Ukraine.
- Yes, no, the made in China.
I think when they first gave,
they changed Rangers in
the Army to tan berets,
and I think when those
first batch showed up,
they all said "Made in
China" on the inside,
and I think this is
pre-September 11th.
I'm going back in the memory
banks a little bit here,
but I seem to remember
that being an issue,
but the levels of
incompetence across the board,
and it's sad that I have to
include the military in that,
but for sure, in
the political space,
I mean, it's staggering,
but I think what we're
getting are people that's...
Well, it's interesting.
The people that are called
to serve our nation
as politicians
also happen to be
very savvy investors.
It's incredible how that-
- It's weird.
- It's so strange.
They enter politics and
making 60 grand a year,
100 grand a year, 120,
and then leave with
the bank account
significantly fuller
than when they entered
because of some very
savvy investment moves,
so there is that,
but the levels of incompetence
and the hypocrisy
that is just ignored
by most of the media,
and that means...
And this all also
ties into big tech
where you can now control not
only behaviors, but thoughts,
so it's not just
buying something;
it's controlling
our thoughts now,
and that part is...
And, of course,
now we have the Ministry of
Truth and this misinformation,
Homeland Security Department.
I mean, oh, my
goodness. It's crazy.
Once again, if I was to write
this, let's say 10 years ago,
as a political thriller,
it would go in the
science fiction
or the dystopian thriller
aisle at the bookstore.
No one would have believed it
if I had written
exact same things
that are going on in
this country today,
and internationally,
and put that into a novel,
it would've been unbelievable.
The reviews on Amazon would say,
"Ah, can't believe any of this.
"This would never happen,"
that sort of thing, one star,
but lo and behold,
look what's going on.
- So with all that in mind,
although I sense that
you're aboveground
because I think I
can see a window
or at least a reflection
of a window over there,
my guess is that you're
a little bit of a prepper
to a certain degree
and that you're obviously
at least self-reliant
to a fairly high
degree, let's say.
What do you recommend
people kinda do
in terms of not being so
reliant on all of these systems
that don't really seem
to be working that well?
- Right, so I've always been
into being prepared in general
since I was a little kid
it just was natural to me,
and as I put more thought
into it as I got older,
I realized that, "Hey,
"for only a very slim
portion of human history
"have we been able to
outsource our protection
"by calling 911 or having
a standing military,"
and then, also,
being able to outsource
where our food comes from
and just having something
that's wrapped in cellophane
that's labeled meat of some sort
that you grab off the
shelf and throw in a car
without a second thought
of where it comes from,
what went into getting
that to the shelf.
We've become very
comfortable in this country,
and for whatever reason,
my whole life I've
recognized that
and just taken steps to be
as self-reliant as I can,
but we had a very
slim window there
where people started,
we talked about
the guns in L.A.,
and where people realized,
"Hey, maybe society is
a little more fragile
"than I thought here,"
and for most of human history,
yes, it has been very fragile,
and for most of the world
today it is fragile.
Look at Ukraine, of course,
so for a little
bit of time there,
some people questioned
how prepared they were,
how reliant they were
on the government,
how reliant they
were on our systems
that get food into
our grocery stores,
and maybe they took some
steps, like you did,
to get a firearm, get
training with that firearm,
but man, a lot of
people went right back
when things started to kinda
calm down a little bit,
went right back to the old ways
and got very comfortable again,
but I think it's just
recognizing that,
"Hey, society is fragile,"
and as a provider, for me, as...
Children, a wife, I'm
responsible for them,
and recognizing that we
have this responsibility,
and what does that mean, then?
Well, it means that I need
to be able to defend myself,
this gift of life and the lives
of my children, my spouse,
and then, be able to
put food on this table.
If we can't go to
the grocery store,
how are we gonna get
get food on the...
How am I gonna provide
for them in that respect?
And you can go
from the smallest,
most seemingly insignificant
thing, until you need it,
like a fire extinguisher.
Does the babysitter
know how to use that?
Do you know how to use that?
Let's go in the backyard with
the kids, make a little fire,
and have them put it out
so that the first time
they need to do that,
they're not scrambling
to figure out
and read the directions
on this thing,
so something from
as basic as that
to having a little bit of
food, little bit of water,
just so that maybe you can
make it a couple weeks,
and then, of course,
you can take that as
far as you wanna go,
and so we're fairly
prepared here,
if that (laughs) if
that makes sense,
but it seems like a
very natural thing to do
is just to be prepared to
protect that gift of life,
and once again, if you were
dropped into this country
or into this planet, let's say,
and were suddenly
attacked by someone,
you wouldn't need a document.
You wouldn't need someone
to tell you that you need to
protect this gift of life.
You would just do it
because it is natural.
That's a natural thing
and a natural right,
so for some reason
over the years
we've lost touch with how
important those things are
and gotten soft, and I think
that will eventually...
I hate to be a downer
here, but-
- No! No!
You're giving me a lot.
Well, first off, you're
very much speaking
to the way I've tried to live
over the last couple years
because I really was,
I felt that I was too
reliant on the entire thing,
which then I got guns, I
started doing gardening.
We had backyard chickens in L.A.
We're gonna get them here in,
we're gonna get them
here in Florida too.
I wanna know.
I started learning how to
do just a little bit more.
I love doing house projects now
and knowing how to do a
little electrical stuff
and knowing how to do things
because you're right.
We all became reliant
on things that,
(snaps fingers), man, they
can go away pretty quickly,
so I got one more for you
that I think ties
this all together,
and so it won't
be so depressing,
but I don't think it
has been, which is,
so for a guy that writes about
some pretty serious stuff,
and we've talked about
some pretty serious stuff
and that our systems don't seem
to be working as we wished,
either domestically
or internationally
and everything else,
are you hopeful?
And what do you see as the
course correction for all this?
I mean, beyond just,
okay, we can maybe fire some
people, elect better people,
but what do you see as,
if you see a real
course correction
to get us to that better place?
- Gosh, we were trying
to stay positive,
and the course correction,
as horrible as it is,
I think it's gonna be
(indistinct) upon us
by some sort of a seismic shift,
a seismic event,
something like that,
that forces that hand because-
- So you think
it's a rock bottom first.
- I think so,
I mean, when you have two paths,
and one is very easy
and comfortable,
most of the country
seems like that's the way
that they're gonna go,
and you have to really make an
effort to go that other way,
to be prepared, to
be self-reliant,
to educate yourself, to
read books on history
and appreciate why we have
these rights and options
and opportunities that we do
and go back to the inception
of this country up until today
and realize the sacrifices
that were made for us,
and now we have
people in this country
that are actively trying
to restrict those rights
that people died to give us
over the course of our history,
so there's an
appreciation aspect there.
I took my daughter to Pearl
Harbor this last December
for the 80th anniversary
commemoration events.
We volunteered with the
Best Defense Foundation,
and we took 64 veterans,
aged 96 to 104,
back to Pearl Harbor,
and these guys, a lot
of them lied to get in
'cause they were too young
to go defend their country,
and so she had this touchpoint
with this generation that
sacrificed so much for us
and then came home
and got back to work.
She'd read about them.
She'd heard me, as a
parent, talk about it,
but it was different for her
to sit down across the table,
share a meal with these
guys, hear their stories,
and they loved talking to Selma.
She's 16, and talking to
someone of her generation,
it was just, it was
incredible event for her,
and I think it changed the
direction of her life, actually,
so that ties back
into that appreciation
of what we have in this country,
and then, what is our
responsibility to those people
who sacrificed so much for
those next generations?
What do we have to do now
so that future generations
will have those options and
opportunities that we enjoyed,
and we're at a pivotal
moment in U.S. history,
and we just talked about
the First Amendment.
I mean, we're on this
platform right now.
We're talking.
We're free to say whatever
we like here, -ish,
but what about this Ministry
of Misinformation campaign,
Ministry of Truth and
all that sort of a thing,
and when we have people
who typically were the guardians
of that First Amendment,
so let's say lawyers,
publishing houses,
newspapers, magazines
that used to be
the front line of defense-
- Gone, gone, gone, gone.
- (indistinct) calling
for censorship.
I mean, that's a seismic
shift right there
that should be alarming
because the one thing that
used to bring us all together,
no matter what your thoughts
are on the Second Amendment
or whatever else was going on,
that First Amendment bound
us all together as Americans
because we'd stand
up and fight and die
for your right to say something,
especially if we
disagreed with you,
and now that's changing, and
social media is weaponized,
and politicians wanna
weaponize against each other
so we can be more divisive so
that they can stay in power
and make those savvy investments
that they are so good at making.
- Jack, I think the final
summation is get a chicken coop.
Is that what you were
basically trying to say?
The way you lit up when
I said chicken co-op-
- Water, yeah, yeah,
'cause we have one
going in right out here,
but yeah, I think it's just,
yeah, appreciating
where we came from
and taking some steps to be
a little more self-reliant
and that educating yourself and
your children along the way.
I think those are the,
sometimes that's all we can do.
- Right on, man. The
book is "In the Blood."
I'm telling you guys,
this cover, it's just,
and it feels like
a freaking book.
I shoulda, the book
should be here.
We dropped the ball on that one.
The book should have been there.
We're gonna link
to it down below.
I've enjoyed talking to
you. I hope you come back.
- Great talking to you.
Take care out there.
Thanks so much.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our
lifestyle playlist,
and if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlist.
They're both right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.